former speaker of the house john boehner
retired from public office nearly six
years ago but in his new book on the
house a washington memoir boehner takes
his party to task his book traces his
rise from his early life
to becoming one of the most powerful
figures in government
and he takes aim at his republican
former colleagues as you can hear in
these excerpts from the audiobook
i don't think ronald reagan would
recognize the republican party today
and he sure as hell couldn't get elected
in as a matter of fact reagan would be
the most left-wing candidate
in the gop these days by a mile i was
living in crazy town now
and when i took the speaker's gavel in
2011 two years into the obama presidency
i became its mayor crazy town was
populated by jackasses some media hounds
and some normal citizens as baffled as i
was
about how we got trapped inside the city
walls under the new rules of crazytown
i may have been speaker but i didn't
hold all the power
by 2013 the chaos caucus in the house
had built up their own power base thanks
to fawning right-wing media
and outrage driven fundraising and now
they had a new lunatic leading the way
who wasn't even a house member
there is nothing more dangerous than a
reckless owl
who thinks he's smarter than everyone
else
ladies and gentlemen meet ted cruz
trump incited the bloody insurrection
for nothing more than selfish reasons
perpetuated by the [ __ ] they've been
shoveling since he lost
a fair election the previous november
the legislative terrorism that i'd
witnessed as speaker
had now encouraged actual terrorism and
it pissed me off
former speaker at boehner joins us now
good morning to you mr speaker it's good
to see you
with the blue eyes you tell a great
story in the book you tell a great story
in the book about colonel gaddafi
giving you sunglasses because he said in
the desert because he said the desert is
not kind of blue eyes
but we really wanted to see your eyes
this morning because some of your stuff
is jaw-dropping so let's get to it
we should be we should we should
acknowledge that you take aim at
republicans you take aim at democrats
you also take
aim at yourself with this a lot has
changed in washington you say in the
world but you have not
you were still the same jackass that you
were 25 years ago that's how you start
now you seem to be calling out a lot of
fellow beeps and so i'm wondering what
you're hoping to accomplish with your
book
let's start with that
listen i wasn't trying to accomplish
anything other than to tell my story
i've had a pretty interesting life a
very interesting career
and i thought would be a good read for
the american people and so i decided i'd
write a book
it was a great uh exercise a great
project and
i'm glad people are finding it
interesting oh it's more than
interesting i want to talk about you and
ted cruz
in particular because you take really
big shots at him
you guys won't be having a glass of wine
anytime soon
what bugs you about him specifically and
it's more than just him
well well this guy wasn't even a member
of the
united states house representatives he
was a member of the senate
uh stirring up some of the crazies of my
own caucus
uh to uh to cause all kinds of problems
and that's probably why i zeroed in on
him
probably the only person in this book in
the way that i did
as i say in the book there's nothing
worse than a reckless
jackass who thinks he's smarter than
everybody else
yeah he said he's one of these guys who
knows all of the answers and we all know
somebody like that
we sure do you say uh in the book
uh mr speaker that in today's gop there
are trump republicans
and traditional republicans but the
trump republicans are contr
clearly in control of the party right
now and i'm wondering if you still feel
at home
in the republican party
listen i'm a republican i'm through and
through
i believe in in spending within your
means i believe in a strong
national defense i'm a republican
but we've got some people in the party
who who believe more making noise
than you do in making policy i went to
washington to serve in the congress
not because i wanted to make noise but
because i wanted to do something on
behalf of our country
and i think if republicans begin to
focus more in on the policies
that we all believe in uh we can unite
the party
uh in a place that uh that americans
will recognize once again well mr
speaker let me pick up on that point in
particular because in the book you do a
very clear job of explaining how
technology changed and that allowed
politicians to go
straight to the public but you don't
really take on the subject of
why that outrage and that fight for
fight's sake resonated with so
many people i mean one theory of it is
that for half the country
america is just changing too quickly for
them to tolerate it is that how you see
it
well i don't get into why the crazies or
the crazies
but i do run into them while i was in
congress and clearly since then
and some people have got a rather sour
view of the united states
listen we're a great country we're a
large diverse
country and we ought to embrace that
it's been great for our country over the
last
240 years and it'll be great for the
next 240 years
if we embrace the fact that we're we're
large we're complex
uh we're very diverse let's put our arms
around it
and believe in it yeah you know you talk
a lot about
uh the diver the lack of diversity in
the party you hit on that but you talk
about the lack of
disrespect in particular you say about
nancy pelosi
i don't agree with much much of what she
says but i do respect her
and that seems to be what's missing
today there doesn't seem to be respect
and there doesn't seem to be tolerance
on either side you say there's a
difference between
common ground and compromise so how do
we get things back on track because it
is
so off in the ditch on both sides of the
aisle really when you look at it
republicans seem to have a special
republicans seem to have a special uh
a special ledge on this particular topic
though go ahead
well growing up on my dad's bar i
learned the art of being able to
disagree
without being disagreeable and those
people in politics that i served with a
lot of them i disagreed with
but that didn't mean i had to be
disagreeable i've got
as many democrat friends we've got
republican friends
you can do this job and respect the
people on the other side
who happen to have different views this
is not rocket science
and when it comes to governing it's
about finding common ground
we're not always going to agree on
everything but the question is
where can we agree where can we come
together and to do what needs to be done
to help the american people in their
quest for the american dream in a better
society
who's the leader of the republican party
now
well there's a lot of leaders in the
republican party just like when i was
there
you know mitch mcconnell plays a role
kevin mccarthy plays a role
but clearly former president trump is
retired
unemployed uh and appears to want to
play some type of a role well over the
weekend
mr speaker former president trump uh
called mitch mcconnell a
dumb sob reportedly for accepting the
election results
what do you think what do you think
rhetoric like that does to the
republican party
well i i think rhetoric uh that inflames
people is wrong
i don't care whether it's from the right
or from the left
it just doesn't help our country in any
way shape or form
and so republicans need to go back to
being the principles of the
as a republican of principles of the
republican party
and frankly i think the party will be
much much better off in the long run
all right you watch golf over the
weekend what do you think about the
results happy
well listen for the last 48 years i've
planted myself
every master's weekend i've watched
every moment of it
and uh i'm real proud of hideki
matsuyama for
his accomplishments he played great it
was uh it's always great theater but
it was just as great yesterday all right
john boehner you say you went from a
regular guy
working to a bar to holding a pretty
good job pretty big job
i want to end with this my favorite
bannerism no need to murder your
opponent
when they're committing suicide thank
you very much john boehner
the name of the book on the house i'm
showing it goes on sale tomorrow
you